-The last time you were here
in person, in 2019, I asked you,
"Would you want to interview
President Obama
when he, inevitably,
wrote a book"?
You said you would,
but it would tarnish his legacy.
And lo and behold,
his legacy is intact...
despite the fact
that he came and did your show
How was that experience?
-It was fun, but I would -
I beg to differ
about his legacy being intac
because now everyone
sees the true color.
We've pulled away the veil
Obama is a Knicks hater! Okay?
A lot of people
did not know that.
The White House hid that
from the American public.
But now it's been revealed
This is the true scandal.
-Yes. Obama --
-It was wonderful.
It was the time of our lives
interviewing him, man.
-Yeah, no.
-He's the coolest person ever.
-It was wild.
-He talked both about the fact
Desus, that you don't have kids.
He complimented you, Mero,
in the fact
that you're raising four.
Were you surprised how much he
knew about your personal lives
-No, because he said --
he said -- He was like --
He's like,
"You know, I watch your show."
-Right.
-But you have to remember --
-Like, in a weird way though
Like, in a weird,
like, you know, like,
"I saw that joke you made
about my jeans" way.
-Yeah, but it was also --
-And we were just like --
-It was also weird
because it's just like --
I was like, "Oh, wow!
He knows I don't have kids."
Then it's just like,
"Wait a minute. This guy was
in charge of the NSA,
the CIA, and the FBI.
How much more stuff
does he know about me?"
He could've really blew it u
on the spot and been like,
"Hey, what were you
watching at 2:00 a.m.
back on August 26th in 201
that you had to turn
the volume all the way down?
And I'm like, "Uh..."
-"Uh, Sir -- I don't know, sir."
"Uh, uh, it was 480p.
Uh, I don't know. I'm not sure."
-You had to --One of you had t
ask -- I think it was Mero
You had to ask for
a bathroom break, correct?
-Yes. Because, it was like -
You know, it's Obama.
So, you know,
I didn't want to go make -
you know, make anything --
hold anything up.
So I was just like, "Oh,
I can make it through this
I'm a 37-year-old man!
I can hold my pee for an hour.
You know? And I could not.
You know what I'm saying?
So I had to get up
and go to the bathroom.
And shout-out to his securit
because they just were like,
"Okay, go this way."
They did not gun-bump me
in the back of the head
like a Jason Bourne movie.
-But you have to definitely --
That's one of those things
when you interview a president
You definitely have to announc
any sudden movements you make.
You can't just get up like tha
and just leave the room
'cause Secret Service
does not play that.
So shout-out to Mero
for being smart about that
So, I was talking
to a friend of mine
who is a New Yorker, as well
and he said New Yorkers
make this mistake all the time
which is we focus so much
on the presidential election
when, in reality,
what will affect our lives mor
is the mayoral election.
It's an incredibly
crowded field.
What do you guys make of i
so far?
-You said it. It's so crowde
that it's, like --
You got to wait for it
to thin out a little bit.
I think the guys --
"The rent is too damn high" gu
is still around.
-He's your guy?
-You know what I'm saying?
I don't know. Is he?
We don't know.
Like, what are the Vegas odds?
I think there's like 40 people
running for mayor right now?
-Yeah. Right now --
-Let's get it down to like 10.
-Right now the -- right no
the New York mayor race
is like "American Idol" in the
beginning when they're jus
speeding through people
and people get the paper.
They're like,
"Oh, I'm going to LA!"
Right now,
you just got to be calm,
because there's
a lot of people right now
who have no policy,
but they're very flashy.
You don't want to get attached
to someone and know they're no
gonna make it through
to the next round.
So we got to keep
a close eye on it.
And some of people
are a little too whimsical
If you got pink hair
and you got, like,
a talking rabbit,
that's your gimmick,
We really don't need you
right now.
We need an actual leader.
New York, please choose right.
-Please.
-Do you think it's a harder jo
than being president --
being mayor of this city?
-Yeah, for sure. For sure.
-Mm-hmm.
-Because everybody hates you
no matter what.
You could be the best mayo
New York has ever seen,
and somebody's gonna be like
"I hate that guy!"
-Yeah.
-"He's not a real New Yorker
He doesn't eat gyr--
He doesn't even put
tzatziki sauce on his gyros!
-Yes, 'cause New Yorkers
hate the mayor
in a special kind of way.
And as the president, you ca
stay inside the White House.
You don't have to
run into anybody.
The mayor has to run into
New Yorkers all the time,
and nothing -- There's
no older New York traditio
than absolutely
cursing out the mayor.
Just honestly. They did it
to Dinkins. They did to Koch
They did it
to Giuliani, de Blasio.
I did it to de Blasio
this morning.
So, you know,
it's gonna continue.
-Yeah, he thought he was -
he was tall enough
to not get yelled at,
and he found out the wrong way
that wasn't true.
-No.
-He found out the hard way
-He just found out.
When you move to New York
and you're tall
and you don't play sports,
people just call you Big Bird.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't realize that,
but that's a great --
another great thing
to love about our city.
Do you guys have any guest
you're excited about
coming up on this season?
-Ooh, yeah!
We're coming back hard
with the champion of democracy
We got leader Stacey Abram
in the building
for our first episode back
-That's exciting.
-It's always great
speaking with her.
-And I will say, Desus, seeing
you in front of those shoes,
even though your interview
with Obama was great,
one of my favorite
political interviews
in the last five years
was you guys going over
how much shoes cost
with Bernie Sanders.
-With the gawd. Bernie Sanders
-Just the purest --
It boiled down the essence
of all three of you.
-Yes, but how great
was the look on his face
when I told him the prices
It was just seething rage.
[ Laughter ]
At that moment, I've never
wanted to vote for him more.
-Yeah.
-It was just like, "Wow."
-I should point out --
it wasn't like the shoes
were twice what he thought
they should be.
It was, like, a factor
of, like, 30.
-Like, 30. Yeah, yes.
-Exponentially more
than he thought.
He's like,
"These, uh, look like
they are around 45 bucks,
I would say."
-When that ran,
you could actually hear
everyone's head exploding
when they realized
capitalism is a scam.
They were like, "Whoa."
-"Whoa!"
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here, guys.
I can't wait for
your new season to start.
It is always
nothing less than a pleasure
This third season of
"Desus & Mero" premieres
January 31st on Showtime.